hi i'm raymond simpson i'm a museum
assistant here at the peabody museum in
entomology
and today i'm going to show you a bunch
of
insects from central and south america
that are quite interesting from a
biodiversity standpoint and also from an
evolutionary standpoint
so before i get started i'm going to
kind of give you a nice
overview of the various arthropod
species
that we see that are non-non-butterfly
and moth actually
so this is a good diversity a good
illustration of the diversity of
basically non-lepidopteran arthropods
from the tropics so lepidoptera would be
butterflies and moths so there's
many other groups of insects
that are basically reach peak diversity
in the tropics
so you have everything from non-insects
like
scorpions scorpions whip scorpions
tarantulas and then centipedes and
millipedes
and then you also have insects
that vary from this large katydid
which is a type of related to
grasshoppers you have these large plant
hoppers
cicadas roaches
and beetles so today i'm going to
just give you a little brief overview of
a lot of this
amazing interest insect diversity that
is found in latin america
so there's multiple themes that come
into play when you're talking about
insects
in the neotropics with these type of
insects
and there are um
a couple one is basically size which you
kind of got an idea based on these
a lot of insects range from very small
to very
large as illustrated by a lot of these
insects in the box here
this is kind of the large size variation
in insects
but you could see that there's it ranges
from
basically the largest like this is one
of the largest grasshoppers in the world
but there's also grasshoppers that are
much smaller under an inch in length
so there's grasshoppers that range from
basically a few centimeters
to nearly like basically like
10 centimeters across
and there's a lot of variation in both
size and shape
so here we have a basically these are
two types of
orthoptera which are crickets katydids
and grasshoppers
this is a winged grasshopper but this is
a wingless cricket this is like a wida
ground cricket
and this up here
is a wingless katie did and
entomologists studying these can tell
them apart by subtle differences in
morphology
so there's a lot of variation from huge
to very small
but the most striking thing you can note
in
arthropods in the tropics is what we
call sexual dimorphism
and sexual dimorphism is is basically
the sexes of insects the male and
females
have different morphologies so
dimorphism means there's two
different morphs based on the insect
being male or female
so in this beetle this is called the
hercules beetle
very common through central america the
male
which is on the bottom here has these
really cool horns
and i will get him out
very carefully so the male hercules
beetle
has these weapons that basically what
they are um for not only impressing a
female
but also fighting with other males so
they have this like
multiple horned protuberances
that help it fight other males so the
males will actually
line up with each other and fight each
other
and whoever whatever male knocks the
other male off their perch
wins and then the females which don't
have horns
um will choose them because they're
obviously the fittest
of the males so the females are
generally of most
scarab beetles are a lot less ornamented
than the males here's another example of
a
hercules beetle you could see the the
horns being
quite long and ornate in a lot of these
some of these dynasties or hercules
beetles can get quite big so you can see
compared to my hand this is a very large
stag beetle and you could tell by the
horns
the horn morphology is different in each
species so if you get them if you get an
individual of each of these beetles you
can tell what species
is based on the horn shape
another type of beetle with this
interesting dimorphism
and basically uh like
an adaptation is this um
serum biscuit or longhorn beetle you
might be like why the heck does it have
such long
legs like that um you could tell it's a
longhorn because it has long antennae
but what are these long legs for
but the males and these are actually
using these
in a basically territorial
fashion to basically display
and to challenge other males so if you
see any sort but
there's a pretty wide variety of these
adaptations that insects have
and if you see these extreme adaptations
in any insect either of color
shape or ornamentation that usually
indicates some sort of sexual selection
is going on
where the females are actually choosing
males based on these
interesting and extreme ornamentations
that they have
so going back to what i mentioned about
size
size is very important
to insect diversity because
different sizes allow for different
niche space niche being the place
the basically the role that the organism
has in its environment
so if you have different sizes of these
are all praying mantises
for example if you have different size
praying mantises they could occupy
different niches
so you could have smaller ones
interacting in the same environment with
larger ones
where if you have a single praying
mantis like you do in the in like the
northeastern united states
you have one species and that's it not a
lot of insect diversity is possible
if you have one size so if you utilize
multiple sizes
of insects you can fit a lot more
diversity into a particular
area of forest so these are actually
types of mantid
like this here is called a um a hooded
mantis
and these actually sit on the tops of
like banana like basically
large broad shiny leaves and they
perfectly blend in
to their background and this is a more
typical manta similar to the mantids you
get in the united states
with the typical raptorial four legs
that you can see here for grasping the
prey and then you have smaller
more bark mimic mantises that actually
mimic bark they actually sit on bark and
you can't see them
when they're on the bark because they're
so perfectly camouflaged
and then you have these small these
small species
which actually mimic other types of
insects mimicry meaning they look like
them
so these actually mimic wasps so these
mantids actually look like wasps
so they not only are able to sneak up on
potential prey by looking like a
completely different type of insect
but they're also able to
have the mimic the protection from
potential predators by looking like a
wasp
so you kind of have this double usage of
this
mimicry that they use
um another good example of a large
insect that you probably don't ever want
to encounter or get stung by
this is called a tarantula hawk so
tarantula hawk
is feeds on
tarantulas as you'd expect
so you can see this is a typical
tarantula that you'd find in the tropics
but these wasps are adapted to kill them
or paralyze them and feed them to their
larva so
one of these wasps will actually go over
flip this over on its back
sting its belly where it's less
protected and then drag it across the
ground
and when the wasp brings it to its
burrow it'll put this body of this
paralyzed spider into a burrow
and lay eggs on it and the larva will
actually eat the spider
alive which is kind of brutal but
because they are adapted to hunt such
large prey
these pepsis wasps have become so
like gigantic um that
their their stings are very like you
don't want to get stung
because they are very very painful but
they don't tend to be very aggressive so
as long as you leave them alone
they're only interested in spiders
they're only interested in hurting
spiders not humans
so we kind of touched on a little bit
when we're talking about size
and size diversity but
another very important thing about
tropical insects is camouflage
and with a lot of these not insect or
non butterfly arthropods
they're more worried about getting eaten
because they can't fly so a lot of these
will tend to look like things that
aren't edible
so the walking stick is probably
something a lot of people have heard of
but the walkie stick is the best example
of
bibicary of a non basically a non-living
thing
so these imagine this on a tray would be
almost perfectly camouflaged
from predators so in the case of some
walking sticks
you have this very large one here on the
bottom it's hard to say
this is a very large species but you
could tell compared to the one i showed
you before
this is a lot thicker and more textured
so it's adapted to live in a different
area
than the the more gracile skinny walking
stick that i showed you before
so this one is going to be camouflaged
on like a prickly bush like a pricker
bush or something a brush that has some
roughness to it um
this is another type right up here a
little bit bigger
so um while i have this on we have some
a lot of people are familiar with plant
hoppers in their gardens in the tropics
you get
giant plant hoppers so these this one
here is called a peanut bug
because its nose is elongated into this
really cool
inflated projection on the front
and as you'd expect this is for display
this is for attracting a mate
so the males with the most inflated
noses are
selected to reproduce
so a lot of these plant hoppers are
important predators of plants by sucking
the juices out of the stems
but they also reach fairly impressive
proportions in the tropics
cicada which a lot of people are
familiar with in its head
the cicada is very well known for being
more
like this size in the united states but
this is what they get to be
in the tropics and just imagine how loud
that is when that thing's buzzing
so finally i'd like to finish
on basically diversity of color
and beetles are the most numerous
basically the most numerous arthropod
group on the planet
probably millions definitely hundreds of
thousands of described species were
probably in the range of millions of
species when it's all said and done
and this is just an example of some of
the amazing diversity within a very
small group of beetles called the jewel
scarab beetles
and these jewel scarabs are ranged from
just kind of normal browns all the way
to this brilliant green some of them are
literally chrome they look like they've
been dipped in chrome
and it's the jury's still out and what
what the
the adaptive advantage of this chrome is
but green
is apparent because just like the hooded
mantis they could
blend into plants very well these green
ones and then the brown ones are very
good to blend in with
ground cam basically ground debris and
leaves
so a lot of these jewel scarabs are
basically found throughout latin america
and they commonly come to light so a lot
of people like to collect them
and observe them because they are
quite easy to see so in entomology
there's a lot
of things to study and a lot of ways to
study there's a lot of life history we
don't know
a lot of biodiversity is completely
unstudied and anybody from
somebody like me to any or any
citizen even untrained person that
doesn't know much about insects
can contribute to entomology by simply
getting out and studying
and learning and observing and you two
could make
positive contributions to entomology
plus they're just really beautiful
and fun to look at so thank you very
much
you